-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are here with
Kumail Nanjiani.
So, last time we spoke, you were
promoting "The Eternals."
You got in superhero shape to
enter the
Marvel cinematic universe.
This was a very different
weight change
for this show to prepare for
Steve Banerjee.
-I'm the only one on the show
who stays completely clothed
the entire time.
And it was a joy.
It was so good.
Even my one sex scene,
I have my shirt on.
-Whoo!
-Very mixed --
-Very mixed.
Like, what are they saying?
-Yeah.
-Are they whooing for
the sex scene
or the fact that
I kept my shirt on?
-Yeah, yeah.
"Whoo! We don't have to see
all of it!"
-Yeah. "Whoo! It's implied!"
"Whoo! I'll imagine it!"
-But you did, though --
You know,
we could even see from the clip,
you obviously had, you know,
your cast of actors
who played male dancers
in the show.
Obviously,
they're stripping down,
and you had to do
many dance scenes
over the course of filming it.
-Yes.
-How were those to do?
-You know what
was great about those?
So, we had,
like, fabulous actors
who are also, like,
Broadway-trained dancers
who were
the dancers on the show.
And, you know,
when you sort of do --
When you're recording it -- So,
we had, like,
background artists,
like, you know, 100 in the room.
And they're all women,
because men were not allowed in
to see the show back then.
And because
when you're recording,
you don't want
the sound to disrupt
whatever dialogue is happening.
So we would tell the audience
to, like, mime the reaction,
so they'd just be,
like, doing that.
But every time
they yelled "cut,"
they would, like, explode.
Every single time.
They were like, "Yeah!"
Day after day, week after week,
the same audience.
Anytime somebody, like,
ripped off their pants,
you'd hear, like, a...
[ Gasps ]
...like a gasp every time.
Like you know
what's under there.
You saw it five minutes ago.
There was one -- You know,
there was one part where
one woman,
one background artist,
has to, like, rip off one of
the stripper guy's pants,
and she turned into
an animal every time.
Every time, she was like, "Aah!"
And we'd yell cut,
and she'd come to like,
"Okay, what'd I miss?
What happened?
When do we shoot?"
We're like,
"We've done 30 takes.
You've been great every time."
She turned into an animal.
It was great.
And you see like,
"Oh, this is why
Chippendales was
such a success,"
because it created the space
where women could, in public,
show a part of themselves
that they weren't
allowed to until then,
so it was really, really --
-It was ahead of his time
in a real genuine way.
-It really was.
It was really exciting,
you know?
It was like,
energy was up every time.
-You --
We were talking backstage.
You were a producer
on this, as well.
You know, so many more
responsibilities as --
You know,
you've been a writer before.
Obviously,
you've been an actor before.
Did you enjoy the producer side?
-It is so good to be
involved with all parts of it,
but then you kind of
don't have an excuse.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Because I've acted in movies,
and I watch it,
and I'm like,
"Oh, no, why did they..."
You know what I'm talking about.
Go look at my IMDb,
all the green splats.
All the green splats --
that's their fault.
This one, if it's a green splat,
it's my fault.
-Yeah, that's your fault.
-Yeah,
'cause you're always like,
"Why did they use that take?
Why did they do this."
Da-da-da.
But here -- But I love
the editing part of it the most
because you don't have to get up
early in the morning,
and you can just,
like, fix everything, you know?
It's great.
-I mean, I think,
certainly in comedy,
when you so often --
By the time you've said it,
it's already too late.
It must be nice to actually get
in and be granular with it.
-Yes. And sometimes with comedy,
you're shooting a scene.
You know, you're doing
a scene of comedy,
and you shoot it like
20, 30 times.
By the end,
it's not funny at all,
and you're like, "I don't think
this is funny anymore."
And then, when you watch it,
you can really be like,
"Oh, no,
it was funny the whole time.
We had just gotten,
like, sick of it."
Like if I made another,
you know, Ents joke...
-It wouldn't go as well.
-...it wouldn't go as well as --
You know, the first time,
it crushed.
Also, I realized
we did that in break,
so that -- This is --
-I'm really heartbroken
for our at-home audience.
During the break, Kumail did
a really funny joke about
the tree people from
"Lord of the Rings."
And when -- I mean,
there's no way to prove it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They remember.
-That was not the reaction
the first time.
-No. This is maybe --
I mean, so much went --
So, you made --
Let's just track what happened.
You made an Ents joke
that nobody laughed at.
Then you called it back,
realizing that the people
who were watching at home didn't
see it bomb in the first place.
-That's right.
-So you somehow did
a worse version of a joke
that got no laughs
the first time.
-Yes. I did a callback
to a bomb joke.
And you know what?
Kind of killed with it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is that?
What is that about?
-Yeah.
-How did that happen?
-I mean, that is --
I mean, the way
you're doing comedy these days
is so interesting.
Yeah. I just do callbacks.
I don't do the first one.
Who has time for
the first punch line?
-Yeah. Everybody likes
the callbacks
more than the first --
-That's true.
-Yeah.
I go right to the third tag.
-This is very much like,
"Why don't they make the whole
plane out of the black box?
-Except for,
like, way less relatable.
-Yeah.
-I think this might be
just for me and maybe you?
I'm not sure.
-This part that we're doing
right now?
-Yeah, I think it might --
-I think mostly you.
[ Laughter ]
I take it back.
I'm enjoying it, too.
-You explained a callback
to a joke
that we had to explain
before we did the joke.
-Yeah. Every part of this,
I feel like, is special,
and I don't feel like you can
get it anywhere else, you know?
-Yeah. I don't know why.
-You're not -- Will you please
do a special called
"Just Callbacks"?
-It's just the callbacks.
-Yeah.
-That's actually a great idea.
I'm just, like,
referencing things
that I never referenced
in the first place.
-Yeah, but,
like, really confidently,
like it's going to land.
-Right. Or, like,
doing a catchphrase
that I've never done before,
but just, like, landing it like
it's a catchphrase,
like, "Now, that's what
the thing is."
Is that a good catchphrase?
-I bet you could
get away with it.
-"That's what the thing is"?
-"That's what the thing is."
Maybe workshop that part.
-That part is my catchphrase.
-What?
-That part.
-You know what you
should call it?
"That part 2."
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's it.
That's what it is.
Just the callbacks.
-Thank you for being here.
Congratulations on the show.
It's really cool.
And it's great to see you.
-Oh, man, always --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kumail Nanjiani, everybody.
"Welcome to Chippendales"
is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back with
Matt Rogers.